listen
this sound is the first evidence of the
big bang
and this is a story of two radio
astronomers who discovered proof of the
beginning of everything
this is the horn reflector antenna at
bell laboratories robert can you tell us
what this thing does it receives radio
waves coming from the direction it's
pointed to
and funnels them into a receiver that's
robert wilson radio astronomer in the
early 60s he and his colleague arno
penzias were tasked with measuring the
brightness of the sky using the horn
reflector antenna but no matter where
they pointed it the antenna read a much
larger signal than the pair expected our
immediate reaction was that there must
be something wrong with our system they
thought it might be interference from
the horn itself or new york city or even
some pigeons living in the horn you know
we thought about a collection of
ordinary sources that are in the very
distance that just didn't seem to be
possible so they reached out to a group
of researchers at princeton university
led by astrophysicist robert dickey who
had been scouring the sky unsuccessfully
for evidence of the big bang arnold
called and
dickie picked up the phone and they
started hearing things like atmospheric
radiation sky brightness
all the things that they were working on
dickie put the phone down and said boys
we've been scooped
robert and arno had measured what dickie
and his team were searching for the
elusive cosmetic microwave background
radiation
he thought about a big bang source of
the universe realized that it would be
very hot and therefore full of radiation
and as the universe expanded that
radiation would simply cool
and whereas it was
extremely hot to start with by now it
would simply be
microwaves now it's so cold that it
would just be radio waves
and this nut pigeons or the noisy city
was exactly what had been causing
headaches for robert wilson and arno
penzias the two groups of researchers
from bell labs and princeton each wrote
complementary research papers with their
findings they wrote one about the theory
we wrote one about our measurement and
we published them i think unlike many
changes that occur in science there
really was a paradigm shift with very
little push back
it was huge there was now evidence of a
new theory for the beginning of the
entire universe over a decade later
robert wilson and arno penzias were
awarded the 1978 nobel prize in physics
how'd that feel robert felt pretty
strange to win the nobel prize i didn't
feel comfortable being on the same list
with einstein but despite robert's
humility there's no doubt the
significance of the discovery it gives
us our earliest picture of the universe
from which we can extrapolate back to
very early times
as one of the centerpieces of cosmology
[Music]
you